hi for the fourth layer you need the
inner edge pieces you need the center
edge pieces and you also need the middle
Center pieces so you put the middle
Center pieces on like that then the edge
Center pieces go next to them and then
finally you put the groove down and you
put the inner edge pieces on
so now you should have four layers
complete alright so what you want to do
now is to create the final spherical
support using the four last wedges that
you have I have already put in three of
them so what you want to do you have an
empty groove here you're going to take
the smaller interlocking clamp and
you're going to face it downwards like
that so that the lip is facing inwards
and down and then you're basically going
to just slide it on top so it should be
nice and flush then what you want to do
is you want to do the same thing with
the bigger one you're going to face this
lip away from you and so that you see it
downwards like that and then you're just
going to basically rest it on top of the
other one so this is basically what we
did for the first the first step as far
as getting the support bar then what you
want to do you want to take the wedge
and you want to put it on top of the
bigger piece it should probably snap a
little bit so now you have the big piece
to small piece and then you have the
wedge then you're going to take the
remaining two pieces slide them into
each other like that and then you're
going to snap it into that final spot
okay so now you should have the
spherical support completed alright to
complete the fifth layer we're going to
take the remaining center pieces and
also the remaining edge pieces for these
layers so what we're then going to do
I'm going to put the orange blue edge
piece the outer edge piece going to put
the red blue outer edge piece in place
make sure the groove is facing downwards
and then we have the blue corner edge
piece that slides in like that
and then the two edge centerpieces so
now your cube should look something like
that all right guys so the top layer is
the trickiest to reassemble what you do
first is you first put in the corner
pieces and then all of the edge pieces
so I have 40 place these two corner
pieces and these eight edge pieces what
you then want to do so I'm going to put
in the other two corner pieces this is
the green orange yellow we're gonna it
basically fits in there like that but
you see it doesn't go in that way so
what you do is you put the tip down and
you got to kind of push it in hold the
cube and just snap that piece in so now
that piece is snapped in do the same
with the other ones if these pieces come
out they usually all you have to do is
just slide them back in okay make sure
that this this sphere structure here is
also intact you don't want it to start
coming pieces coming out so then you
hold the yellow on top do the same with
the other corner okay so now we have the
two corners in place now we could put
the remaining edge pieces what you want
to do for the edge piece is you're going
to put the inner one on first and then
you're going to snap the outer one next
to it
do the same for the other side okay then
we're going to put the remaining four
edge pieces here the same way we just
did those two alright so now you should
have all the edges in place and all the
corners now we're going to have to
resort to even more forcing the pieces
and snapping them in what you want to do
first is we're going to place two of the
middle Center pieces in place here okay
they're basically going to move around a
little bit so what you want to do next
is you want to place the edge Center
pieces in
all right now that should hold the
center the middle centerpiece is a
little bit more firmly then what you
want to do is you want to place these
edge centerpieces in so this one's gonna
go over here as you'll see it kind of
snaps in okay so your cube should look
something like that
now what you want to do is you want to
put these corner pieces in the corner
center pieces in so it doesn't matter
any any corner centerpiece can go either
either way so you're basically just
gonna have to put the tip in hold the
edge of the cube and then snap it in
don't worry about breaking the pieces
they're pretty sturdy I could say that
okay so then you put the tip in all
right so now we have the corner pieces
in as well now what you want to do if
you did accidentally dislodge these
pieces here you're gonna have to just
push them back in so you should have
these pieces still intact here you could
use a pencil or whatever so now they're
back in okay so now what you want to do
is we're going to put the middle Center
pieces on the next ones
and then we're going to also do the edge
pieces
okay so now you should have four pieces
remaining what you want to do is you
want to get the edge Center pieces in
and then we're gonna just pop those two
corner pieces in so make sure that this
side is facing towards the outer edge of
the cube you can't do it with with this
little lip here facing out so that face
the lip here this little edge goes
inward like that and then the hook if
it's facing left it goes on the right
side that pops in last one pops in and
now we got to do it just put these
corner pieces in so hold the cube so
that you don't accidentally pop the
pieces out okay so now we have one
corner in place and we just need that
last piece to finish up the entire cube
so the same thing you're just going to
basically force it in there hold the
corner of the cube and there you go all
of your pieces in the cube should now be
reassembled and you should find that the
cube turns normally I'm not sure if I'm
going to have any videos on actually
like lubricating the cube they said in
the DHL shipment not to basically lube
the cube too much so obviously they're
assuming people are going to lube up the
cubes a little bit and I probably am
guessing it would help out the 6x6 a
little bit as you could see the internal
structure the reason that these pieces
pop out is because the two pieces that
are seated against each other one of
them has a groove that basically
interlocks into that Center structure
while the other one is kind of just
loose in there I should have showed you
while it was open but you'll see that
the piece is basically just slide out
and I think that's why these two pieces
usually pop out alright guys so just
leave any comments or questions on my my
inbox or you can leave it on the actual
tutorial on reassembling the cube I hope
this video has helped you reassemble
your V cube six
and thanks a lot for watching